spoke briefly with Russia's foreign
minister lavrov on the margins of our
G20 meeting today
I told the foreign minister what I and
so many others
said last week at the United Nations and
what so many G20 foreign ministers said
today
end this war of aggression
engage in meaningful diplomacy that can
produce a just and durable peace
president zielinski has put forward a
10-point plan for a Justin durable peace
the United States stand ready to support
Ukraine through diplomacy to end the war
on this basis President Putin however
has demonstrated zero interest in
engaging saying there's nothing to even
talk about
unless and until Ukraine accepts and I
quote the new territorial realities
while doubling down on his brutalization
of Ukraine
independent of what Russia does
we showed here in Delhi what we will do
deliver results on the problems most
affecting our people's lives